[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
he [ __ ] did a lot of creepy things
down there man uh
rest in peace you know he was good to me
yeah he was a creepy [ __ ] living with
his brother
poor guy
and the guy's talking like they give a
memorial in the back you hear you're
like this is such a [ __ ] last time i
saw this guy was doing blow yeah off the
strip his ankle
and this candy he's a loving father sure
yeah he should have seen him that
night how much he loved his skin when he
had his tongue up that [ __ ] yarm's
[ __ ] [ __ ] with coke island
[Music]
all those loving fathers they always are
the dirtiest [ __ ] in the world
how about catheters have you ever had
that in like for oh i just did a
colonoscopy i august fought and it was
nothing again i felt the needle a little
bit it was just hot man when i was
hospitalized like years ago when i owe a
deed that's right uh
you wake up and everything's right you
don't remember them putting anything in
so i had a catheter in
but i didn't it was fine i didn't feel
anything but a nurse
tripped over the tube
and i was like
oh like i screamed i was like what the
she and i because she goes it's not
supposed to go like that that was her
apology i was like what and she was like
yeah i stepped on it that's why it like
yanked on you
it was the [ __ ] most painful thing
and her way of handling was just
not supposed to go that way i i think i
knew that i got blind drunk with what's
the the old the guy that was running
houston improv
that that guy no not not a trey no the
creepy guy the creepy guy yeah yeah yeah
he's a creepy fellow the creepy guy's
dead the other guy no no no he's a
creepy [ __ ] they they sent them to
arlington he's the rapist he's the truth
i wasn't singing yeah yeah they put them
they put them in they put them in
arlington
you know dan murr was a [ __ ] dirty
coach
like
like a filthy cocaine
and he
he would get so coked up that you think
he had a stroke his lip would turn like
his lip would just go upwards
so one night at everybody for years one
night when i had the really bad sleep
apnea and i really wasn't sleeping i
didn't know what uh i didn't know what
god
rest in peace i didn't know what the
sleep apnea what the effects were yet
uh-huh i passed out one night really
hard and also i wake up to the door
banging and it's joe rogan pre-marijuana
when he was [ __ ] miserable
i always say he was an ape you ever see
the evolution of an eight that's when he
was an eight yeah if you didn't know joe
no marijuana it wasn't
it wasn't it was like spurts there was
something missing thank god eddie talked
him into that
because you didn't know why he was
anti-drug yeah anti-fucking drug you
know if if bert came over and the next
day he'd call him you know burke crystal
had like 16 [ __ ] beers he's got a bad
problem you know and he would just say
that i remember we went to see doug
stanhope that's how it started and he's
like [ __ ] doug is funny but
somebody's got to talk to him about his
alcohol his own way joe nobody says
things like that like nobody i go why
would you say he goes why would i say
that he had 11 beers and four shots of
tequila on stage
that's how uptight joe rogan used to be
because i don't even recognize that guy
no no
i did an edible the other night that was
so [ __ ] strong
that my wife woke me up at 20 to two on
the couch and i thought she goes you had
a look on your face like i was a demon
i go bro i was i passed out i was
dreaming about food you were like when
she woke me up i was like oh my god
thank god you woke me up i was having a
dream about [ __ ]
she went in the kitchen and filled up a
water bottle
and i walked straight to the kitchen
opened up the [ __ ] cabinet and there
was a half a jar of pringles i just
started pringling it
i just ate the [ __ ] pringles then i
made a ham and cheese sandwich i ate
that and then i went right to bed
i was so [ __ ] high like the next
morning i woke up and i saw the american
cheese
because when they slashed at the butcher
he puts paper in it and i saw it like
who ate the cheese lit oh my god
i ate the [ __ ] cheese last night how
strong was the edible
100 milligrams they're stronger than
debt oh my god i took two to new york to
shoot this movie and i took one of them
one night when i had insomnia slept like
a baby
and then the other night i took on the
flight back you took the 100 milligram
on the playback flight back i started
freaking out that the plane was gonna go
down
and then they pulled the plane over to
the side because of the rain in the
midwest and they kept saying if we don't
leave in 30 seconds and 30 minutes we're
probably gonna have to cancel a flight
until tomorrow morning i'm high as a
[ __ ] and i'm thinking maybe i took the
wrong plane i switched
and maybe because i was supposed to
leave saturday you're out of your mind
at this point out of my mind i'm an hour
in with earphones the plane was at the
gate for half hour and they made the
edible go up and then we drove around
all over [ __ ] new york city with
kennedy airport we were cutting off
ubers i'm like where the [ __ ] is this
plane going and i saw a little arabs
pulled over to the side [ __ ] you
i'm trying to drive uberx
we're in that [ __ ] plane after a half
hour i'm thinking we're in the air
this is all right i am thompson jesus
man now directv you know mint uh yeah
jetblue has the directv yeah so i'm not
watching the tv i'm focused on the radio
and i'm thinking we're in the area and i
open up and i see 20 other planes i go
where the [ __ ] up
we have been driving for an hour
i don't know where he went around
kennedy airport we're flying around for
[ __ ] an hour and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this pilot going i thought we
were in the air with it i swear to my
daughter's grave i was so high i thought
we were in the [ __ ] i took i took 20
milligrams on my last flight to new york
and that was too [ __ ] much for me
really 20 milligrams would do something
new
first do something i took 50 on the
flight there man [ __ ] up i was [ __ ]
up dude you got to eat a half of this
with the wine it goes [ __ ]
he's
you know i went you know i went to
joey's store with why are you doing more
of that
i joey i'm not eating it buddy
if you don't need it you'll have to
leave
[Music]
you didn't split any of it
how hard was it to quit
coke
it was uh
easy because i was done
you were already like i was
at that point i had a lot of variables
why
and
it was a lot easier than people think i
was done
but once i just i missed uh
i realized that i wasn't getting high to
get and it wasn't enjoyable like
marijuana right now
i could see it falling off the map any
day now really yeah i can see myself i
can see myself
just doing edibles or something to calm
me down for a while just to say but the
little bit of lung i got left oh it's
stop smoking it doesn't take a genius to
know i got the beginnings of the same
you know like you know you don't have to
be a genius so you can do it then do
that man save your life and that's what
uh
with cocaine it was the same thing i
just knew that
when you uh i was doing cocaine for so
long i was getting jolts in my spine at
the end of the night
jolts of electricity like castro's
that is terrifying that's not good
that's right that's correct
you're like yes that means i was getting
one a night you know once a week and
then it started to get to one night
that's [ __ ] terrible i started to a
night i could just see my wife waking up
to go pee
and seeing my fat little legs in the
kitchen laying there purple and you're
like yeah you know i said i can't do it
can you turn the bass down in my voice
sounds a little tinny bring that beat
back
[Music]
but uh but yeah ronnie be
like those big cigarette boats and yeah
yeah cut off shirts like hulk hogan used
to wear florida's maniacs dude it's a
crazy statement really crazy it's a
really crazy state and it's one of like
it's like nevada in the sense that like
if you [ __ ] off want to be like [ __ ] off
society i'm kind of like i do [ __ ] on i
bend a lot of rules i'm kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like it's a great state
to thrive in you know like there's so
many the most scumbags i've ever met in
my life was living in florida really
yeah for sure so many [ __ ] scumbags a
lot of racists a lot of races a lot of
everything yeah a lot of everything
there's a lot of everything it's a big
it's a big hybrid pirate state it's it's
been [ __ ] getting mauled on since god
knows when yeah you know you know
columbus was down there i mean it's just
jesus was down there everybody's been
down there right before i i started
working out and stuff you said like you
got to let your
blood drain through your legs and ever
since then i keep seeing really big guys
with like the permanent bruises and like
the like the skin eating away on their
on their
most horrific thing
i was i was there with my girlfriend at
the grocery store this dude was walking
around didn't even have pants on it just
gym shorts and was picking up bags of of
ladies chips with his legs literally
rotting away and i was like what is
happening you see it all the time where
you want to go like why is it okay for
you to show me that like where these
these dudes have like it's their their
leg is like a tree trunk where there's
no and there's no like it's all the same
size from [ __ ] his thigh to his ankle
and there's like these crazy open blood
lines yeah open sores
you know i'd work to get my ankle that
skinny
yeah
but i do the same [ __ ] every night dude
you work i get on my ass yeah pop my
legs up yeah i split i do a v i can
[ __ ] v on the wall now because i've
been doing it i pick my legs up i creep
i go to the side i suck all this in but
i do the other side and that this helps
you go to the bathroom that's good for
your digestive tract cleans your kidneys
it's yoga [ __ ] but the best move is your
feet up because the blood goes down
and now it gets processed instead of
getting purple on your [ __ ] feet yeah
you know if you don't do nothing if you
put your feet up and watch [ __ ]
daytime football or [ __ ] day and he
chips that blood ain't going nowhere
these people you see at the airport
walking around for you you want to grab
them are you [ __ ] serious you said i
saw one with a tattoo i don't know what
it is with people with fat [ __ ] legs
that are purple putting that parrot on
there like that's gonna throw you off
that money you spent for the ink you
could have spent a 24 hour fitness for a
[ __ ] trainer you know so you got your
fat friend saying it's a cool parrot
look at your [ __ ] vein wait till the
parrot blows his head blows the [ __ ] up
that was an easy weekend [ __ ] great
time what i was telling you was
that 1983 i was walking past the window
one day i was doing laundry on the
lord's day
minding my own [ __ ] business not
bombing just doing laundry football was
on i wasn't in the mood
i was living in snowmass village and i
was in creekside apartments and i'm
walking
and i look at this window as i'm walking
by and the windows open but there's a
screen in front of it but the door is
right there yeah all i have to do is
stick my hand rip the screen on stick my
hand i got this [ __ ] fool's paradise
i knew the guy i saw him early up at the
[ __ ] bar up at the mexican place and
i knew there was some type of drugs in
this house yeah so i stuck my hand in
there went in i got a chunk of hash i
got some jewelry
i got like 1500 in the rubber band
and i got a
like a couple grams of blow you know
and i ran out and i went home and i
buried the 15 grand yeah and i took the
jewelry and i put in one little state my
buddy was a property manager uh those
days for
some property management company and i
went to condos that were under
construction yeah and i would put all
the stolen loot in the safes when we'd
have the combination that's the only way
i got away with all that [ __ ] so they
came to my house there was nothing in my
house the blow i kept that was going
down
and the hash i had a little spot under
the closet where i ripped up the carpet
and with a knife i picked up the wood it
was like my little i always since i was
a kid i was always one of those creepy
dudes that wanted to be james bond yeah
yeah i loved picking i didn't fight
boards yeah i love picking up
floorboards and digging it out i love
all that crazy [ __ ] to me that was the
easiest heist of my life december 18
1983. i remember i called my buddy to
say hey i'm sending you a package
tomorrow look out for a chunk of half
just put some jewelry move the jewelry
and we'll split it 50 50. it was like a
ton of jewelry yeah i don't know he goes
it's my birthday okay and i made a
mental notes and every year december
18th i call him on his birthday because
of that robbery my point
my point is
vegas was easier than that
that's how much of a good time i had in
vegas and that's where you learn that
strategy that's why i love people going
dog i couldn't follow him because you
died before you even got on stage
don't give him the limelight thank
thompson girl for coming on stage and
attack them like a [ __ ] pitbull for
four minutes
until they forget who the [ __ ] tom
segura even was don't forget if you
attack them hard yeah the first four
minutes thomas and girl don't even exist
they won't remember you on the till the
way out i'll remember him he was funny
too and you're like ah
because you attacked them i used to lose
the war in my head
as a young comic yeah i can't follow
that clean stuff
look at all those people with white hair
in the audience yeah it's not until i
eliminated that factor i don't want to
see the audience
i don't give a [ __ ] who they are yeah
just go go out there and do your
material because once you start catering
and bantering that's where you learn to
bomb
well
that chinese that yeah that there goes
disc and you smell my faith no there
goes this set
you know like if you go i have a bunch
of chinese people i'm gonna do a i said
about the guy i rear-ended that was
chinese
there goes that eight-minute bin if you
don't do that bit you just lost in your
head you're totally right do that bit
with all the confidence in the world
that you have
do that bit like if you were in front of
20 white people in fact
i want you to turn to them as you do
that bit because the more confidence you
show
the more they're going to laugh their
ass off because they're chinese they
know they can't drive they can have a
hard time walking around the airport
they all stop at the door at the airport
you even go to your you know like russia
they get to your gate yeah they all stop
and look around like they say what the
[ __ ] are you looking at move
move the [ __ ] this is the end of the
exit
they want to sit there and look around
man this is
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]